we know each other he's my best friend
he's my lover well not anymore a source
tells ET Wendy Williams has filed for
divorce from her husband Kevin hunter
the talk show host has split from her
husband of 21 years amid speculation
that he has been cheating on her with a
woman who allegedly gave birth to his
baby last month rumors of infidelity
have plagued the couple for years and
while Wendy never confirmed the gossip
she did sort of address her marital woes
on her show in March she was still very
much in love with my husband you know
marriages have abs and flows marriages
are not easy and don't ask me about mine
until you see this bond but now a source
close to Wendy tells ET quote wendy is
done she should have been done a long
time ago but she tried to make it work
they went to counseling but Kevin just
kept lying to her the baby was it and he
kept lying about it until the very end
ET sat down with Wendy's longtime friend
Paul Porter in March and he weighed in
on the state of Wendy's marriage to
Kevin who until now has been her manager
and an executive producer of her TV show
why do you think Wendy continues to stay
with Kevin I know Wendy loves her
husband they built an empire together
of course Kevin came in a little later
in Kevin's bless he never finished the
ninth grade
and they built you know tens of millions
of dollars together now you told me Paul
that Wendy hired a private investigator
and found out about cars about an office
and also a house yes she she went over
to the house to see if it was true she
and she found out it was true that's
part of the pain Kevin she's been seeing
this for almost two years now do you
think Wendy will ever leave him I think
you know with the birth of the new child
things are destined to end
[Music]
[Applause]